I'm very excited to give the talk on this newest kid on the block, the JNJ5322 tri-specific
targeting CD3 positive T cells, BCMA and GPRC5D in multiple myeloma.
These are my disclosures.
So this molecule now has a name.
It's the romantomic.
So romantomic is a tri-specific antibody that targets CD3 positive T cells and BCMA and
GPRC5D antigens, which are both very heavily expressed on plasmoplasts and plasma cells
in multiple myeloma patients.
So the rationale for this drug is that targeting two antigens simultaneously with T cell redirection
may increase the affinity of binding to the tumor, increase antitumor.
activity by more comprehensively attacking the myeloma cells as it will cover cells that
are expressing just BCMA and just GPRC5D and then dual expressing myeloma cells.
And this, we think, possibly could overcome tumor heterogeneity and tumor loss-mediated
mechanisms of resistance and further improve clinical outcomes.
The difference in this molecule is actually that...
it comprises novel binding domains and low CD3 affinity selected in vitro to enhance
the on-tumor effects and minimize the off-tumor impacts.
So the phase one study of romantomic was discussed earlier by Dr. Vandenong in ASCO 2025, and
this evaluated romantomic in triple class exposed, and actually in the United States,
it also included triple class refractory multiple myeloma patients.
And the key objectives were identifying the recommended phase two dose, safety profile and preliminary efficacy.
And there were various dose expansion cohorts that are being looked at, at a dose of...
evaluating a dose of 0.4 all the way up to 300 milligrams with Q2 or Q4 dosing.
They were all given subcutaneously, and ultimately we landed on a step-up dose of five milligrams one time prior to 100 milligrams Q4 dosing.
and ultimately we landed on a step-up dose of five milligrams one time prior to 100 milligrams Q4 dosing.
milligrams Q4 weeks as the recommended phase 2 dose for further evaluation.
The baseline characteristics for this trial is it included about 126 patients that actually
achieved remantamic, and the median age was 64 in the overall cohort, and about 31%, so one-third
of the patients had high-risk cytogenetics, which is pretty much what we see in practice.
All 100% of the patients were triple-class exposed, and about 53% of the patients were
triple-class refractory, and about 20% of the patients were both BCMA or GPR-C5D exposed,
and 80% were GPR-C5D or BCMA-naive.
So, the overall response rate, particularly at the APIT-2D dose and in patients that were
BCMA or GPR-C5D-naive, was a hopping.
Was a hopping.
Was a hopping 100% in 27 patients that received this dose, with very high rates of VGPR or
better of 96%.
The median time to response was 1.2 months at a median follow-up of 12 months, and these
responses actually deepened with time.
The subsequent results that were demonstrated at ASH 2025 by Dr. Krishnan further revealed
a deepening of the responses, and a higher percentage of patients, about 89%.
So, we're at the same rate of 90% achieving CR or better.
The PFS, the two-year, sorry, one-year PFS overall was 95% at the APIT-2D dose, and 74%
in all the doses combined.
And at 12 months, it was about 93%, and for that 18-month follow-up, still maintained
responses at 80%.
So, in terms of the safety profile, neutropenia was one of the main factors that we saw.
Major hematologic adverse events noted in 42% at the APIT-2D dose, and about 31% of
these patients had actually grade 3, grade 4 neutropenia.
The incidence of infections was quite high, 81%, and about one-third of those patients,
so 33%, still had grade 3, grade 4 infections.
The incidence of CRS was, interestingly, 53%, and majority of it was all grade 1, grade
2.
No grade 3, grade 4 CRS events were noted.
The taste-related changes, which we see quite commonly in talcetamab, which is the other
GPRC-5D binding Bispecific, was quite lower, so 58% in all grade 1 and grade 2.
Similarly, nail-related and non-trash-skin-related toxicities were also in the range of 50% to
60%, all grade 1, grade 2.
No grade 3, grade 4 events were noted.
Oh, sorry.
So, there was one dose-limiting toxicity.
It was observed in the RP2D cohort, which was neutropenia, and overall, five dose-limited
toxicities were observed in all of the doses, and there was actually one death, unfortunately,
in the RP2D cohort because of pneumonia.
So, the incidence of CRS was actually reduced to 20% with the use of prophylactic tocilizumab
in the RP2D cohort, and all of it was grade 1, and no grade 3, grade 4 events were noted,
and actually no incidence of ICANN.
The incidence of ICANN was noted at the RP2D dose, which is quite impressive.
Most of the infections that were noted were actually upper respiratory tract infections,
about 39%, and only 3% of those were grade 3, grade 4 infections, and the incidence of
hypogammaglobulinemia was still about 50%.
Interestingly, in the follow-up results that were announced at ASH, the cumulative incidence
of grade 3 or grade 4 infections actually plateaued within the first year of the therapy
at the RP2D dose.
So, that's a good thing.
No additional deaths due to infections occurred in the subsequent follow-up period, and especially
with the use of IVIG being incorporated in all these patients.
And also, in terms of the oral adverse events, which is a major limitation in using talcetamab,
as we know, compared with TAL or the redirect study with use TAL and TEC together, a relatively
low incidence of oral treatment emergent adverse events was noted, and a shorter duration of
these side effects of about 8 weeks.
And unlike TAL, the mean weight loss over time was quite minimal at the RP2D dose, and
consistent with TAL, the changes in weight were actually irrespective of the changes
in taste.
So, in conclusion, romantomic with one step-up dose of 5 mg prior to the 100 mg Q4 subcutaneous
dose was selected at the recommended phase 2 dose to be evaluated in further studies.
It appeared to have a safe,
or in fact an improved safety profile. Similar or improved safety profile as compared to other
Bispecific directed against GPRC5D or BCMA. CRS events were low, mostly grade 1,
grade 2, and further reduced with the use of prophylactic TOSI, supporting the
use of TOSI prophylactically in outpatient setting especially. We still struggled with
grade 3, grade 4 infection rate of about 33%, but this plateaued within the first year of therapy,
and we still struggled with grade 3, grade 4 infection rate of about 33%.
With incorporation of IVIG treatment, the Bispecific actually had an improved
oral adverse event profile with minimal to no weight loss over time, and with really good
overall response rates of 100% and responses deepening over time, with a 12-month PFS of 93%
and 18-month PFS of 80% in patients that were BCMA or GPRC5D naive. I think we have a very
solid drug in our armamentarium.
As we try to cure multiple myeloma, and just highlighting the studies that are incorporating
this tri-specific. So there's the phase 1 studies that we talked about, and then the phase 2 study
with the trilogy 3, which is looking at this drug in a large number of patients in relapsed
infecting myeloma, and then also trying to move this drug to the frontline settings and newly
diagnosed myeloma in combination with DARA or LEN or POM. And then the phase 3 study,
which is evaluating the tri-specific as compared to TEC. And that's all. Thank you.
- Thank you.